so i wanted to talk today um
a little bit about
a proposal that i've been working on
sort of to hopefully
give us a better dom api to work with in
the browser
i've been working with
different browser vendors i've been
working with uh
mozilla uh the internet explorer team
i've been and i've been talking with the
w3c about coming up with a good uh api
that we can all work with
so
what the core of my proposal
uh
centers around is uh the node list
no list is a highly underused
object in java in javascript in the dom
right now you can get a no list um
in a couple ways you can get a note list
but if you want to do
child nodes for example child nodes will
give you a node list if you do get
elements by tag name that'll give you a
no list queries select or all that'll
give you a no list
and all these no lists have sort of
different states some node lists are
static in that they're just they just
don't change like if you if you do query
select or all you'll just get back
effectively a glorified array uh that is
an array uh it's much less useful than
an array um and um that's not changing
but if you do get elements by tag name
that's also a no list but it's updated
live every single time a new for example
div comes into the page that node list
gets updated dynamically
there's also the concept of a html
collection uh it's an uh
it's in uh it's it was in the current uh
specification but it's also in html5 and
it's not really clear why html
collection exists since it is just a
node list um but so we have this kind of
you know bastard child existing here
that really should be killed off or
something but anyway so what i wanted to
do is take this concept of a no list
which is kind of neutered right now it
doesn't really like i said it's just
sort of an array that doesn't really
have any meat to it and make an actually
useful part of dom
um
the reason why i wanted to do this is
that
um
this concept of that you see in a lot of
frameworks now um
is i i think sort of originated by what
we did in jquery originally which is
effectively instead of operation instead
of operating on a single element at a
time you operate simultaneously against
sets of elements
and as it stands right now the browser
doesn't really provide a mechanism for
doing that
so i wanted to provide some abilities to
make that possible
to start
i
i'm introducing a new method called a
create node list
and create no list uh works sort of like
create element and uh other functions of
that nature
and you can pass in an array of nodes an
object essentially any object that kind
of looks like an array of nodes
so you you can pass in uh for example um
you could pass in that and it would
understand it and turn that into a node
list as the output now effectively what
i define a node list as uh because since
up until this point there has been no no
definition of what a node list should be
it's just sort of this kind of
mysterious sort of list
so what i say is that a no list is
you know has has these properties uh for
each individual node that's contained in
the in this container has a length
additionally all the nodes are
guaranteed to be in document order so if
you have a whole bunch of
elements in it they're all they'll
always come out sorted in the correct
order in which they're in the document
additionally there will be no duplicates
so if you if you had multiple if you if
you pass them multiple document bodies
for example you would only get one body
back
so this is what sort of set the ground
rules i mean this is this is uh pretty
standard and that all the all the node
lists that you get right now in the dom
have these properties you know they they
work like this they all come back in
document order and they have no
duplicates so i just wanted to uh
uh maintain that state
um but the where the really interesting
stuff comes in is
uh if if we have this no list uh uh
that's coming from get elements by tag
name query selector etc and we have the
ability to create custom node lists
we it becomes really useful to be able
to extend the node list prototype
so
effectively what my proposal centers
around is extending the node list
prototype with a whole bunch of really
useful functionality that we can use
in web applications
additionally um
if we don't end up killing off html
collection we should make html
collection inherit from node list uh
because right now they're kind of two
separate things that don't really
uh inherit from each other it's all
really weird
but but again i think html collection
should just die um
so uh where do you see html collection
come up is if you do like uh dot
children it's all from the like the old
dom zero days like if you do
document.forms
uh document.links you know stuff like
that that no one ever uses anymore uh
except in like crazy legacy apps uh but
all that's all html collection
um
so uh one of the things that's really
easy to uh to implement
is is a chaining like functionality
and one of the concepts uh um
the the way you get a chaining like
thing is that on the node list prototype
you introduce a create node list method
so that means from any note from any
node list you can do another you can
create another node list and when you do
that the parent node will always point
back to where it came from so just as an
example here
so this isn't this doesn't work right
now but just to show you as how it would
work
um so for example if you did if you got
the child nodes and uh from the body
element
and you asked for its parent node you
would get back to where it came from so
you so any node list that you get you
can always go back to where from from
once it came
so additionally for example if you did
uh like query selector all and then you
did a query selector all on the result
set on the node list you could always
get back to that original uh no list
again so in this way you can very easily
traverse through
these result sets
and again so this is something that
doesn't uh uh work it yet but i i'm
proposing
additionally on the uh so some of the
things i want to see on the
uh node list prototype are a whole bunch
of array methods there are a bunch of
things that would be very very useful to
be able to use against no list so for
example different ways different ways of
looping so like if you'd be able to have
like a for each map filter all of those
um and in some of the default
built-in array methods like slice concat
things of that nature now all some of
these like slice concat
um
map
and
yeah there's a yeah
slice concat map and filter will all
return new node lists as a result since
they all modified the node list in some
way
so for example
um
we said uh query selector oh
uh you find all the divs
and then uh you know we map it
so the
map for each and that and they have to
come from
uh
that's been a firefox now for quite some
time and it's in a part of ecmascript
five so here we go we say um
give us all the parent nodes of all the
divs
for example this so this that's this is
a an operation that can't be achieved
through normal
css traversal uh but it's something that
we could do using the power of
javascript um
okay so um
there's a whole bunch of different
methods uh
uh that i want to introduce
and all these methods typically
end up what i say is they end up
bleeding through
to the elements themselves so just as an
example
uh you have a traversal so i showed an
example of it
um
so for example if you do
uh
similar to what i saw before so you
could say get elements by tag name
and then say get
elements
by class name
so i mean uh you get you could
effectively chain these operations
together because it doesn't really make
sense now because what happens now is
that we're restricted to using these
methods only on either the document or
on an element
and or or in the case of the query
selector a document fragment
when it makes a lot of sense to be able
to use them against sets of elements
simultaneously so in this way what we'd
be doing is finding all the divs that
are on the page and then finding all the
elements with the test class name in
that are in all these divs
and so what would be happening
internally is that it would be
concatenating all these result sets
together and then returning one unified
no list back as a result so again like
each of these are going to be returning
no lists again and again like the node
list will have for example the parent
node which is pointing back to the ray
of divs um or sorry the no listed divs
um
so uh i propose that we bring over a
query selector all uh i also have some
proposals for fixing the selectors api
because right now the selectors api has
a lot of missing functionality in it um
in clear including um
uh uh
there's one uh there's one that i
proposed was scoped query selector all
um
and additionally a mattress selector so
being able to say you know do these
elements match this particular selector
and additionally a filter selector so
being able to take a set and reduce it
down to a smaller node list that matches
a particular selector so the parent node
property of a node list points to
the node list
i mean if you
uh
i mean the thing is is that
um
like i'm cool
is that a parent node yeah because like
paranoid like i think of like the note
like
i think of like a node's actual pairing
in a dom tree and you're trying to if
you're trying to like if in all these
other places we're trying to interact
with the difference between a new list
and an individual node it seems like
like that's
that's like
what you're calling a paranoid for no
this is a different idea than a paranoid
for it i know
um you call it parent's set and allow
yourself to get like a stack trace for
your set construction that could be i
mean the reason why i like uh a parent
note in particular
um
i mean
there's nothing semantically wrong with
it and at least in the fact that it is a
parent node it is still a node uh but
the thing is that it's um
uh
you know it's it's giving you the
ability to con you know to traverse
through much in the same way that you
would traverse through in a normal dom
tree
um
so i mean because theoretically if you
traverse back far enough if you said
parent node parent node that would give
you document uh so you would be able to
you would be able to get back uh from
where you came originally either way you
did it um
parent node list yeah
it is it sounds singular
you know it doesn't sound like a list
okay
all right um
it's not a huge issue in either way but
um okay yeah um
if i'm apparent no list fantasy apis i
call it heredity
all right
um
let's not talk about fans so um
additionally uh i want to make it so
that if you
call any of the base methods provided in
uh in the dom uh so if you call you know
append child remove child uh any of
those you know insert before anything
that can take a dom node can also take a
node list
so for example you can say append child
no list and it'll insert every single
one of those elements you no longer have
to loop through each individual
individual element and append each one
and much in the same way that uh
document fragments work
with the document fragment you can
insert the fragment wholesale uh and it
works in the same way you can insert a
no list a whole sale
uh so again so anything that can take a
a dom node a pen child remove child
everything
uh also this uh it should also implement
uh the event interface so if you do add
event list or removementlister dispatch
event uh all of those will bleed through
to the uh the actual elements themselves
so if you say add event listener click
it'll add each individual element in the
node list
now here's where things start to get
really interesting so since we have this
nice api
for encapsulating all this functionality
we can actually solve a whole bunch of
really hard problems
um
namely there's two problems that i think
are particularly interesting one is the
problem of having mutation events
uh and also the problem of good dom
security
so if we so in the case of mutation
events for example right now we uh
browsers
uh
uh some browsers implement mutation
events which allow you to
um
listen to a particular point in the dom
tree and wait you know and see like when
an attribute has been modified in an
element or when an element has been
inserted or removed from the page it's
all really slow and because the problem
is is that it's all synchronous
so like for example if you
um
if you in if you have to go through an
insert in 500 divs that's going to
trigger 500 events and each one is going
to be on each individual element it's
it's just it's fantastically slow and
because the browsers can't delay it uh
there's no way for them to optimize it
so there was a proposal there was a
number of proposals um
that came out uh to try and fix
mutation events uh the there's a page on
the w3c site where all the browser
vendors proposed made different
proposals um the only one i felt that
had some merit was one proposed by the
ie team
and
um i didn't like the the particulars but
the one thing i did like is that these
the main changes they made was that they
made it asynchronous they just no longer
guarantee that the mutation events will
occur synchronously
so i effectively take that concept and
apply it here
so what happens is
um there's so uh at least in in my
proposal like if you do create no list
for example uh the result that's coming
back from that will always be static um
the the live load live no lists to begin
with are really kind of crazy
i think every browser vendor would
appreciate if live no list just didn't
exist uh since it would it would make
things a whole lot faster it wouldn't
have to maintain try to maintain this
state all over the place
so the way i counteract the existence of
these live node lists um is there's a
new query method
so for example here um it makes a little
bit bigger
um
oops
all right
so
so for example here
uh we do uh this is the example i used
earlier so we do queer selector all div
we find all the divs in the page and
then we do a map uh and we get all that
all the parents of those divs so again
this is this is a selector this is a
traversal that you can't normally do
uh with it's just plain css um this is
something that you can only do through
script
so then later on in your code
uh the page has obviously been updated
some new divs have come into the page or
some some devs have been moved around
and they now have new parents you want
to get the current results set so all
you have to do is say
uh parents.query
and this returns a the new
result set the new node list uh based
upon the previous uh results so the way
it works
is it actually it goes back up through
the tree so
each individual method
that modifies uh the state you know that
modifies the no list it returns a new
node list so for example here
query selector all is modified such that
uh at any at any point it's possible to
go back and re-query again you can yeah
so we could just say
uh um if we do a very crude something
like this we say uh divs
um then we can do like a
we could do an interval
um and then every 13 milliseconds
um
you know re-query and do something on
those divs and then this will give us
the new result set and it'll re-query uh
those results so in the same way
what's that does that modify the node
list
it returns a new one it does not modify
um
so that's a bit that's a big thing is
that none of the methods that i propose
and modify the list itself uh it's
it's not immutable but at least that's
just good practice just not not uh i
think that's like one of the things that
was that's was done very wrong like we
have like dot reverse for example uh in
the array api and that modifies um and
like just stuff like that that this was
just wrong um
okay so we can do the query so not only
does the query re-run the previous
selector all but it also reruns the map
again and anything else you've you've
changed along the way so in this way you
can get you can always get the new
result set and when you run the query
you don't have to know what those
original steps were to get the result
result so could you remember how you had
parent note for a note list could you
call up to the parent parent parent and
then re-query the parent and then
use the the
end result at the very bottom of all
those chained queries that you're saying
yeah so yeah and that that's exactly
what it's doing internally is that you
know internally all what it's doing is
saying um
it goes back to this step it goes back
to the map step and it says do you have
a parent that can re-query okay go to
the parent first then it says do you
have a parent that you
query it says no it runs this query then
it goes back down again uh so it's
recursive in that way um
so but the nice thing so now we have a
way to re-query a result set
we can add in events
so we can add in an added and removed
event to the node list itself
so we can say okay when something has
been added to the node list or removed
from the node list but it's not it's not
limited to just just elements or or
css selectors you can have complex
things like functions that can be
running and manipulating the state in
that way you know maps or filters or
things of that nature so what you can do
is you can you can effectively reproduce
live events you know um so you can say
all right queer sector i'll find all the
divs
set a class on them and then when new
ones are added set a class in them so
this is going to set a class on all the
divs under page now and all the divs
that ever will be in the page
um and so and then uh here's the
implementation of live events it's like
three lines uh so if
if you so you say dot live you pass in a
function and it runs against all current
elements and all future elements so i i
don't i don't think this would be a good
thing to land in the in the first
iteration api but it would be something
but it's so easy to write like any
framework that wants to extend this api
can totally write it um
okay so building uh then so this is
something that can provide a great deal
of flexibility uh something that isn't
capable right now with like delegation
for example uh with delegation you're
you're restricted to only working with
events whereas with this case you can
work with anything you're modifying
classes or or what have you
um
so the next thing is uh the next thing
the huge advantage here is security
um
so i've been talking with uh with
crockford about this and what's really
nice about this particular api style is
that it's really easy to secure and what
i mean by secure is that right now
within the dom uh anytime you have
access to a dom element you can walk
straight back up the tree get to the
window and wreak havoc you can you can
do whatever you want and call well i
mean the the typical example is you know
you call an alert and you're you know
you're you're home home free
um
but
i'm introducing a new method called
secure and what that does is if you run
it on a no list it returns a new node
list that is completely locked down and
it's locked down in some very critical
ways in that nodes are no longer
accessible on the notes the list itself
so if you if you say no list item at
item zero it's just gonna be nothing
there's not it's gonna be undefined
um
additionally uh but but but that's okay
because all the nodes are gonna be
encapsulated within the node list itself
so all the nodes will be there and so
like you could call like dot remove or
or any of the other uh uh methods that
exist but without having to access uh
but without exposing the actual dom
nodes
so
just as a example here
so if we call a query selector on
some widget and we you return a secured
version of that element or sorry of that
node list
um
for example so if you try to call parent
node or parent node list
that will return null if you try to walk
back up the tree
take a break out that'll return an empty
no list try to access first element
that'll return undefined you try to loop
through to get to the elements each of
the elements will be null
um
but what's nice is that even though it
looks like it's crippled like this you
can still say you can still say all
right nodes query selector all
uh div dot foo
uh then you could call you know like
append you know some stuff yeah or you
know like you can still perform dom
operations against it but without uh
exposing to the user that that dangerous
path of being able to walk back up the
tree to get to the window
so again like this is this is a dom api
that that continues that
uh uh specifically obscures um
uh that particular way out yes what
happens when so you've got methods like
append child here right
on a node list you've got the append
child method uh yeah so uh one thing it
has so um
uh we're all right yeah talk about some
of those yeah um
and there you go okay okay so what what
happens when say you give it an argument
i mean obviously this this will be
incorrect but if you say something like
you've got another list you call a pen
child document dot create element do
you've created one div
where whereas you might think you're
creating one div for every item in the
list you're really just creating
one div and appending it
over and over to every item in the
collection
um
so the one thing that obviously that'll
have to be uh uh worked out but the way
at least we
uh
we solve it at the moment at least in
jquery for example is that we clone the
the first one's the real insertion uh
and then the second through nth ones are
clones of the original
um yes what happens if you create a new
element
just using like
like i assume you have in this example
you have access to that protectorate
element
um
like if you append
do you actually have that access if it's
secure mm-hmm yeah you can append to you
can paint it off if you can
and you append that and then use that to
walk up well okay so so to clarify so
there's um
presumably uh
so there's there's a separate sort of
api here that i i didn't mention which
is the ability to create dom nodes but
not through the traditional create
element means because like right now we
don't have like there isn't an api
specified for doing you know uh uh
html to doc to dom fragment um and like
that needs to exist and like any of
these methods should be able to take a
string html string and be able to still
work um
so
uh and the case so so to clarify what
what you were saying you wouldn't be
able to call document create element in
this secured
environment in this theoretical secure
environment simply because you wouldn't
have access to document to begin with um
uh something because if you did then
what's the point of having it be secured
you're already free um
so uh one thing i want to mention real
quick so
um these so these are things that i
haven't um i haven't completely
specified yet um but it doesn't really
matter since uh their implementation
isn't critical like all like
uh
the implementation for these are like
two or three lines per item it's not
massive um
what i consider to be the critical part
is getting this good initial api out
that we can build off of
and in at least getting this specified
in browsers so that we can extend it and
build better apis um
and then so one last thing um that i
wanted to mention because i think i'm
out of time here is that um
in order when i'm i'm so i'm working on
this and again i'm working with you know
mozilla ie um and uh the w3c
is i'm working on implementation it's
pure a pure javascript implementation
that implements the full api and a full
uh test suite to go along with it so for
example here's accessory i'm over 500
tests at the moment um and i'm just
chugging along and adding more and more
tests uh to prove that this
not only
works but is actually feasible and works
in current browsers um so hopefully
while we're waiting for browser vendors
to implement it which hopefully
shouldn't be that long um
we can actually use it in the interim
um so any questions really quick before
i have to succeed uh to the next person
where is this published
uh it's not published i'm publishing
this month um
it will be up at uh
i'll be publishing it a couple places
yeah
um
so at least um uh
my my goal is to
uh is this month to finish to finish the
test suite and implementation
and publish those
and then work with um
uh
uh doug doug shoppers over the w3c um
and work on a draft of the uh uh
recommendation
um so the
and like i said i'm already i'm already
communicating with
um the ie team and the mozilla team on
implementations
but i i'm hoping at the very least that
having a test suite and a sample
invitation should be enough to get them
off the ground uh and towards
implementing it
yep i figured you said this before but
when you're
do you're calling a pen to the pending
an entire note list to the document um
is your view of the implementation that
it would use a document fragment in the
internet to
apply them all to the document at once
or
um i mean
i'd imagine that internally it would
probably work similarly to a document
fragment um
but it's a little bit different in that
like um like for example if you call
clone node on a document fragment that
clones the document fragment
and incidentally the contents of that
fragment whereas what i'm proposing is
is more it's everything just passes
through so if you were to theoretically
clone uh uh the no list you wouldn't be
coding the no that you'd be cloning the
contents of the node list
um
so another question yeah uh what's the
impact of this work on jquery how is it
impacting your mindset within the core
right now
um
so it's impacting in some ways so i'm uh
i'm deprecating some things in jquery
that just um
uh should hope should help to get us
towards
uh
because i i consider this to be a much
more uh pure implementation um i'm also
very interested in being able to do that
um
the thing i mentioned the the dot query
uh like being able to re-query state
like we don't have that right now in
core but that seems like something to be
really cool really useful
um so that's something i'm also
interested in
um i know i have a deprecation page
somewhere um oh that's up on ether pad
so yeah i don't know if that's still
there um
um
yeah so i've been collecting things that
i want to deprecate um but anyway so
yeah i think some of these are related
to
um
uh this er the api that i'm working on
other questions
okay if you have any questions
feel free to uh hunt me down and i'll be
able to answer them as best as i can but
yeah thank you
you